lavez votre avis quelle doit être la la
la feuille de route de la droite il faut
parler pas parler au front national
tendent la main pas tant de la main ce
que je crois c'est que cet épisode un
peu désolant parce qu'objectivement les
problèmes réels de la france sont bien
des égards éloigné de ses enjeux
partisans sur lesquelles nous nous
concentrons de manière démesurée
maintenant à ma demande
oui je dirais que l'actualité a tourné
au delà de cette question alors qu'il ya
tellement de choses me semble-t-il plus
consistante à traiter ce qui me semble
en tous les cas c'est que cet épisode a
au moins un mérite c'est de ces de
démontrer qu'il n'y a absolument rien à
attendre de l'illusion d'une union des
droites et pour au moins deux raisons
d'abord parce que le front national est
en pleine explosion c'est très étonnant
de 2,2 d'espérer quelque chose d'un
rapprochement avec ce serait très
étonnant d'espérer quelque chose d'un
rapprochement avec ce parti qui lui
aussi n'a plus de ligne idéologique
claire et puis et puis deuxièmement
parce que de fait
emmanuel macron a eu le génie il faut
bien le dire de comprendre que le
clivage dont nous héritions été dépassé
et plutôt que de s'embarrasser de ces
questions d'appareil il a il a choisi de
2,2 d'offrir une perspective politique
nouvelle il me semble que nous sommes un
peu devant le même défi et je le crois
et j'avais eu l'occasion de l'écrire
dans vos colonnes pendant l'entré deux
tours de la présidentielle qu'il n'y a
absolument rien à espérer pour la droite
d'un rapprochement avec le front
national que que le front national ne
sera pas notre avenir ne peut pas l'être
et cet épisode le prouve maintenant ce
qui compte c'est de ceux de réinventer
une proposition politique qui puisse
rassembler une majorité de français sans
se laisser enfermer dans ses danses et
ses histoires d'appareils qui sont de
toute évidence quoi qu'il arrive
absolument absolument stérile